bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag à skis
mac tournée vers l'emploi pour la
deuxième année consécutive le vélodrome
ouvrir assez pour toute une journée aux
recruteurs et aux demandeurs d'emploi le
4 avril prochain quatre mille offres
d'emploi seront à pourvoir et 150
entreprises seront présentes où on l
emploi à saint quentin en yvelines ont
fait le point c'est parti
[Musique]
dans son garage de montigny le
bretonneux
christian huard s'attelle à son travail
du jour c'est une dame qui l'a donc 58
ans je l'a vu pour cette 18 ans en
allemagne comme cadeau sa majorité
donc on a demandé de faire un travail de
restauration
soriano en rejetant le minimum de choses
christian demers lui a fait son maximum
pour sa reconversion professionnelle
direction les ateliers du campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité à guyancourt
tout demandeur d'emploi depuis le 20
octobre prochain est actuellement en
formation le pôle emploi m'a appelé je
suis venu j'ai passé un petit est très
simple puis après j'ai enchaîné tout de
suite par la formation le jour de mes
cinquante deux ans que je me trop tard
pour commencer une formation j'étais
adjoint territorial
je sais pas c'est très bien mais j'avais
envie de changer simplement de voix
comme gta triplettes et cyclistes
je veux cette passion-là depuis tout
petit le vélo un secteur désormais
porter et qui recrutent
christian a donc entamé une formation en
sécurité mais qu'à nice y un cycle
durant trois mois en atelier avant
d'entrer un stage pour deux semaines
chez un professionnel
aujourd'hui diplôme en main christian de
ars a déjà démarré son activité avec une
partie récupération de vélo et recyclage
le progès je travaille la semaine sur ma
vie professionnelle en tant que
mécanicien cycle ou le management et le
week-end et le soir à travailler sur
cette partie là du recyclage automobile
vélos motos les secteurs de la mobilité
recrutent
là encore vanessa 40 ans a laissé parler
sa passion j'étais dans le monde de
l'enfance
donc j'ai gardé des enfants pendant
vingt ans le monde de la moto je le
connais depuis tout petit
mais la mécanique pour moi il ya encore
un an de ça je pensais pas enfin ça ne
m'aurait pas traversé l'esprit si je
n'avais pas rencontré une femme qui
avait fait le même parcours que moi
direction le pôle emploi vanessa est
orienté vers le campus de guyancourt ici
on est vraiment on va dire en petit
comité on est les classes de 12 on
s'entend tous très bien en tant que
femme dans un univers d'hommes
je me sens plus à l'aise je pense dans
une petite classe et puis le site est
génial sept mois de formation sur le
campus puis quatre semaines de stage en
entreprise
après ce but c'est de trouver un emploi
ce qui ne devrait pas trop compliqué
étant donné que le monde de la moto est
en pleine de man
on m'aurait dit aventure tonga à l'école
même pour faire autre chose que j'aurais
bien mais je n'ai jamais de la vie je
perds ton à l'école je m'accroche parce
que vraiment je suis motivé et j'ai
envie d'avoir ce c ap j'ai envie de
faire carrière à là dedans donc ben
voilà on fait tout pour 1
[Musique]
là
tout pour approcher demandeurs d'emploi
et recruteurs c'est le but de cette
seconde édition de ce qu'ils emploient
en piste qui se tiendra le 4 avril au
vélodrome métiers en tension entreprises
en demande qu'on fait le point l'emploi
demeure parmi les premières
préoccupations des français sur le baça
saint quentinois les besoins en main
d'oeuvre est important plus de 35000
intentions d'embauchés notamment dans le
numérique 27% de l'établissement
envisage de recruter l'an passé
l'agglomération avait pour la première
fois misé sur une journée événement
autour de l'emploi
une première rencontre au vélodrome
entre candidats et recruteurs
alors ça c'est un bel événement
évidemment parce que nous étions nous
attendions 3000 2500 à 3000 visiteurs
nous avons comptabilisé 4000
comptabilisé dire qu'au delà de ça à
arriver assez on n'a pas pu tout compter
les gens sont restés relativement
longtemps sur le
sur l'événement parce qu'il y avait
différents stands
il y avait une activité dédiée à la
reconnaissance de soi
comment se vendre comment construire un
cv au delà d'aller chercher un emploi
c'est aussi qui a eu des échanges entre
demandeur d'emploi aussi salariés qui
venaient aussi par curiosité ou revoir
un petit peu comment il pouvait se
repositionner son marché du travail les
chefs d'entreprise et donc il ya eu
aussi des relations un peu informels
comme ça informelle mais pas que alain
berger directeur général de hard ans a
trouvé sur ce forum l'ingénieur qu'il
recherchait la société est spécialisée
en ingénierie de la connaissance et de
la formation
aujourd'hui nous sommes 13 avec on va
dire 3 population une population plutôt
d'informaticiens très pointus dont les
techniques de l'intelligence
artificielle de des technologies du web
et puis de l'autre côté nous avons des
consultants qui font plutôt de
l'ingénierie de la connaissance
enfin il y a les acteurs qui vont nous
aider à faire grandir la société ce
qu'on appelle celle où les business
développeur est passé sur ce sujet là
que l'an passé nous sommes allés pour la
première fois au premier forum de
l'emploi organisé par la l'agglomération
je suis un saint quentinois depuis
longtemps j'étais partie en province et
je venais de ré emménagé sur le
territoire et déménagement changement de
changement d'activité professionnelle il
fallait que je retrouve quelque chose et
j'avais préparé mon cv j'étais prêt
j'avais plutôt prévu d'aller chercher
des grands comptes mais le forum de
l'emploi s'est mis sur mon choix et je
me suis dit c'est un bon moyen d'aller
s'entraîner à faire des entretiens
laurent jir intégrera art danse quelques
semaines plus tard forte de ce premier
forum réussi l'agglomération a décidé de
réitérer l'expérience
le 4 avril prochain le vélodrome sera de
nouveau le lieu de rencontres
professionnelles sur place 150
entreprises du territoire des écoles des
organismes de formation et le pôle
emploi partenaire de l'événement au
programme job dating atelier recrutement
conférences et démonstrations et 4000
postes à pourvoir les métiers en tension
ils n'ont pas trop bougé depuis l'année
dernière on a toujours tous ses métiers
d'ingénieurs est dédié au numérique une
très forte demande des entreprises du
territoire qui a poussé l'agglomération
a lancé un label école du numérique afin
dé former les informaticiens de demain
depuis sept centres de formations se
sont installés sur saint quentin en
yvelines à 52,2
l'école de formation viennent maintenant
sur saint-quentin parce qu'elles savent
qu'il ya des entreprises qui sont
demandeuses d'android plutôt de haute
valeur ajoutée massivement donc on
investit là dessus pour mieux répondre
aux entreprises et puis augmenter leur
activité économique c'est en augmentant
l'activité économique des entreprises
que vous augmentez les emplois vous avez
un pôle important entre plaisir un peu
les clés et elle encourt aussi avec un
pôle high tech comme de très haut niveau
qui se monte
vous avez airbus de go thales air france
air m à autant d'entreprises qui
recherchent un vrai savoir faire mais
pas seulement un constat et s'est fait
jour depuis maintenant quelques quelques
années c'est à dire qu'on a un vrai
décalage entre les offres et la demande
donc tout l'enjeu pour nous c'est
d'accompagner à la fois les recruteurs
et les candidats sur une nouvelle façon
effectivement de rechercher un emploi et
de présenter sa candidature
un bon exemple de cette nouvelle façon
d'appréhender le recrutement on peut
citer d'entreprise explose sur lequel
nous avons organisé la récemment un
recrutement sur des architectes
concepteurs prototype pour lesquels
l'entreprise a recruté des candidats qui
n'avaient pas d'expérience et qui ont pu
bénéficier d'une formation préalable à
leur embauche
grâce à pôle emploi et qui aujourd'hui
ont intégré l'entreprise un diplôme
c'est bien des compétences et un savoir
être c'est encore mieux forte de ce
partenariat avec pôle emploi
l'agglomération a mis un accent
particulier sur les quartiers politique
de la ville où la demande en emploi est
importante mais aussi sur les
populations des seniors et des jeunes
car le forum n'est qu'une action parmi
d'autres pour guider vers l'emploi il ya
eu ce qu la schola où on a pris les
jeunes d'occuper v puis à skagway 16 25
en sourcing et pôle emploi ces jeunes là
sont rentrés très vite en activité dans
une cellule commerciale avec au bout de
deux mois un diplô me suis remise des
diplômes
il ya dix jours ils ont tous un job et
en plus nous avons mis en place une
entreprise éphémère au sein de saint
quentin dans la zone commerciale où là
une cinquantaine de demandeurs d'emplois
de plus de 12 mois peuvent être
bénéficiaires
donc c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
également des fois il faut faire des
actions en plus isolé comme ça n'est qu
un impact très fort oui on voit bien que
le maillage est en train de se faire
nous sommes comme le bassin le cinquième
bassin en france le plus employables
et puis on ne force de frappe incroyable
avec toutes les entreprises prochaines
innovations de l'agglomération en faveur
de l'emploi
la plateforme ski emploi.fr son
lancement sera effectif le 4 avril
prochain au vélodrome
ce portail permettra une meilleure
diffusion des offres des entreprises du
territoire
il permettra également de rapprocher
candidats et recruteurs mais d'ici là
les entreprises rencontreront tous les
postulants lors du forum pour l'emploi
bien évidemment je serai je serai
présent je serai présent donc on va
recruter plusieurs plusieurs types de
profils donc on va essayer de retrouver
une perle rare
moi j'ai entendu des fortes demandes du
travail de nuit ça serait intéressant de
voir si une troisième édition on peut
aller plus loin ou pas tout est possible
quand on veut tout est possible
[Musique]
vous savez désormais tout sur le
prochain forum pour l'emploi
rendez vous le 4 avril au vélodrome ciao
[Musique]